on va retrouver justement devant
l'assemblée nationale notre reporter
catcheur technique 4 alors quelle est la
situation sur place on voit derrière
vous des manifestants contre se passe un
état
oui absolument des manifestants qui sont
venus dire leur opposition à ce passé
sanitaire la restriction des libertés
individuelles qu'il implique selon eux
pour le moment il ya environ 150 200
personnes il en attendre encore plus au
fil de la journée
au fil de l'examen de ce texte à
l'assemblée nationale alors au niveau
des députés il ya évidemment beaucoup
d'opposants à ce projet de loi sanitaire
soit ils sont opposés pas sanitaire soit
ils sont pour mais étonnée qu'on ait
retoqué beaucoup d'amendements qui
offrait plus de latitude aux français le
texte a été adopté en commission après
douze heures de débats 600 amendements
ont été ont été examinés et alors
combien d'amendements tout 1112 est un
véritable sprint législatif à des
conditions de débats ne sont pas
optimales sont les députés qui sont en
général assez agacé un autre reproche a
été fait à l'exécutif pourquoi obliger
les français à avoir un pass sanitaire
alors que beaucoup d'entre eux n'ont pas
pu se faire vacciner en tout cas pour
ceux qui le souhaitaient
et à ce propos jean castex a réagi
aujourd'hui au nous trop de nos
confrères de tf1 en expliquant que de
très nombreux 5 millions de rendez vous
allez être donnés pour la vaccination
on les écoute dans les quinze jours qui
viennent on va ouvrir 5 millions de
rendez vous dans cette merde c'est pas
seulement ouvrir pour vous dire vous
rendez vous le 20 août bien d'autres
quels objectifs on a eu bien compris
vous mettez l'accent sur la destination
mais l'objectif alors chiffré ces
crédits 40 millions de primo vacciner à
la fin de ce mois on est bientôt à
rogner oui sauf que c'était 40 millions
fin août
oui on collera et 50 millions fin août
bayer est là pour vous dire cette
semaine on devrait sceller primo
vaccination c'est votre question on
devra en faire deux millions jean castex
a annoncé une semaine de pédagogie pour
remettre en place les contrôles
sanitaires ensuite il y aura des
sanctions
aura fort à faire pour déployer une
pédagogie alors que de très nombreuses
personnes en france sont opposés à ce
passe
il ya également d'autres détails pas de
passes sanitaires dans les abysses mans
scolaire en revanche restaurateurs un
lieu culturel patron de ba devront
contrôler pas salutaire mais pas les
identités des clients
en tout cas du côté des députés bien
c'est un peu la grimace proposait
d'écouter
eric ciotti député républicain avec
coquerel député insoumis et marine le
pen député du rassemblement national
sur le principe je suis favorable à
toutes les mesures qui protègent les
français je suis bien entendu très
favorable est-ce que nous développions
nous accélérions la vaccination la
vaccination c'est la seule solution et
je suis favorable à toutes les mesures
qui pourront inciter à la vaccination à
la ligne rouge est franchie on va se le
faire imposer toute façon on sait bien
donc on va essayé d'argumenter pour
montrer en quoi effectivement à la fois
c'est pas une réponse sanitaire sur le
long terme satisfaisante mais en même
temps pourquoi c'est discriminatoire
liberticide et même ça divise les
français blancs je pense qu'on a plus de
chance d'y arriver mais on va le faire
nous considérons que nous sommes là
confronté à un texte qui viole un des
fondements de la politique de santé en
france qui est le consentement libre et
éclairé à un traitement mais qui viole
également les libertés individuelles et
accessoirement l'égalité entre les
citoyens
alors en ce moment même et bien vous
voyez ici la contestation dans la rue
avec entre 150 et 200 manifestants qui
sont veut
ici devant l'assemblée nationale
exprimer leur mécontentement vis-à-vis
du pass sanitaires et nous aurons
l'occasion tout à l'heure de les écouter
merci à vous katia technique pour toutes
ces précise